the following contains spoilers for the
upcoming season of Game of Thrones hey
guys today I'm going to talk about the
nurses fate in the upcoming season
supported by leaked photos leaked plot
and of course with a few tears of mine
in this video you're going to see
Daenerys at Dragonstone
the nurses meetings with a few main
characters Daenerys rescuing Jon and his
team from the undead army and Daenerys
avenging her alley after Lannisters
conquer Highgarden including all the
events that lead to those big events as
we all know last time I've seen the
nerves in the season 7 finale scene in
which she had been sailing to Westeros
with her dragons the Truckee horde and
the unsullied army along with her Alice
the sand snakes Tyrells and Greyjoy's
and of course with her advisers Tyrion
buries em sandy by her side few months
ago we've seen firstly photos of emilia
clarke known as Daenerys Targaryen on
the islet August alig acts which will
depict Dragonstone in the upcoming
season which means that Daenerys will
land at Dragonstone on the east coast of
Westeros but only with her advisers and
her own armies as we can see from link
photos Dragonstone is the essential
residence of House Targaryen the castle
was built using advanced Valyrian stone
masonry techniques and as a result it
has many anxiety and unique features you
know Westeros the castle itself is very
strong
due to its advanced Valyrian design
which combined when it the isolated
location makes an ideal reduct and
refuge because of these features and its
geographic position along with the fact
that the nearest was born in Dragonstone
it's not surprising then Daenerys will
land in there and from there we'll try
to conquer the rest of Westeros this
reminds us a lot on hang on Targaryen
and his conquest if you don't know why
it reminds a sunny Aegon
let us introduce you with one fact the
place for a gun and his army first
landing in Westeros and mainly a first
Ford is Dragonstone and also from there
Aegon the conquerer to control of the
most of Westeros since then Dragonstone
remained a traditional seat of the fair
apparent to the throne who was known as
the Prince of dragons
in this case it's going to be princess
of Dragonstone now that you know the
major importance of Dragonstone for
Daenerys let's move on Darryl Neher is
his new drone the brand new drone is
going to be at the Dragons top strong
room on which Daenerys will set just as
her ancestors once dead it will
represent the nearest strength her
intention to conquer Westeros her idea
bringing her house the former glory and
her exigency to avenge her family
Daenerys has had her seat at marine but
now she will have throne when a dragon
stone at least until she conquers the
Iron Throne which is her main goal
however as days were passing more and
more main characters for appearing a
dragon stone first of all let's start
remaining of Ice and Fire meeting of Jon
Snow and Daenerys Targaryen
as you can see Kit Harington to us known
as Jon Snow was a feeling set on eyelet
of guest Dalek acts in Basque Country
which makes him the first one who is
going to visit Dania Dragonstone and
they'll have a conversation with her
their lead photos in which Tyrion with
Sandy and Conan welcome Jon Snow and
Davos to Dragonstone with a scene in
which the king in the north and the hand
of the Queen shared a formal handshake
after John and Davos arrive at
Dragonstone it won't take too long to
wait for a meeting between Jon and
Daenerys here is the proof the image was
taken from the distance but that is
without a doubt the meeting between
Daenerys Targaryen and Jon Snow as a
reason of their meeting we can assume
it's the nearest square sent an
invitation to us from Jon to support her
his rightful claim er of the Iron Throne
while John accepts an invitation to come
to Dragonstone to discuss with the nurse
about true Ward is coming and to try to
convince her that the real war is just
about to come it's the one against the
White Walkers and their whites at first
the nurse won't believe Jon statements
about the undead army then his main goal
is to bring her in her house the iron
throne that was taken from them but
Tyrion will try to convince her that Jon
will align about those things pointing
on the fact that jon is honorable just
as his father had been
as the days on filming set that eyelet
of gas delegates were passing more and
more main characters were rying to
Dragonstone this all seen in with John
Davos Missoni and few Dothraki warriors
welcome to just the right T on and few I
remember man at the shores of
Dragonstone
actually the word welcome is not the
most appropriate term for that scene as
we've all expected John wasn't happy
while meaning Theon that's the man who
betrayed John's cousin Robb Stark took
the Winterfell by force including
killing few loyal Starks man we were
wondering where was steam coming from
did he run from the heat of the battle
against your own Greyjoy with fewer
number man to report to the nearest that
the battle is lost well we don't have to
wonder anymore since few days ago the
leaked photos gave us the answer as you
can see from the new leaked photos
filming the sad at plaza de santa maria
king your own finally appear in season
seven set along with Yara and sand
snakes it's now most likely that you
will pledge his iron fleet asserts in
the upcoming season but in return Cersei
will have to marry him similar deal as
he had for Daenerys but that time his
siblings were faster as we can see yara
Alerian train will be captured after
urine stores our fleet and will parade
through the streets of King's Landing
from leaked photos we can see your own
rage on his horse which is decked out in
a great-looking face plate leading Yara
and chains through the streets full of
King's Landing citizens were welcoming
their new hero euron greyjoy Yara is not
the only one is going to parade through
the streets of King's Landing
they're also captured Illaria sand and
her daughter tyene by this parade
victorious urine will prove to everyone
else that he destroyed the nearest
Sally's and accomplished his promise
that he gave to Cersei as well which
will obviously be helping her to make
the rhein a little longer
most likely supported with a marriage
deal also from leaked photos as we can
see they are missing a bar enemy RIA
still send snakes in our opinion and
also supported by League plot are going
to die during the battle fleet against
Europe in this very moment they are not
leaked photos which can confirm the fate
of Yara Alerian tain after they paraded
through the streets of King's Landing
there is a possibility of the near same
Corrales but in our opinion with two
sick villains like urine and stir see we
don't even want to imagine what's going
to happen to them on this filming set a
director Marc mullet was also spotted
which makes this scene happening either
in 2nd or 3rd episode it's going to be
interesting to see how will the nearest
react on the fact that realities are
captured and they're probably going to
be executed let's continue with Jorah
Mormont's unification in Daenerys Bala
crew was filming in samaya
from leaks we've seen Jorah talking to
Tyrion as Daenerys approached escorted
by the track as her guard and had
conversation with Jorah
now there is also question the jerk cure
his greyscale or did he fail in his
mission but returned today any enemy to
help her as long as he can before it
spreads that much until it makes him
king himself well we'll have to wait a
little longer to know the answer
ginjury will also meet with Danny
finally he is going to appear in season
7 and will meet Daenerys ginjury first
appeared on filming set on Mariola beach
in Baraka the leaked material shows the
Davos interior had a little problem with
the scored think injury from King's
Landing to Dragonstone but injury sold
that problem with to work hammer strikes
and scene ended with those three while
they were pushing the boat offshore
now when the most main characters are in
Dragonstone such as Daenerys sandy where
is Tyrion grey worm
Jon Snow Davos team Greyjoy ginjury and
Jorah next what we see from leaked
photos is filled and preparing to lead
Dragonstone and Pharaohs with Daenerys
from leaked photos we can see Jorah and
Daenerys talking scene in which Danny
says farewell to her advisor who in
return vows to his queen as the scene
goes on the nearest turns to Jon
meanwhile Jorah helps
man to prepare the boat these men as you
can see in the photos are double sank
injury as we've told
ginjury has been brought to dragonstone
the scene doesn't surprisingly as John
Davos injury and Jorah push the boat and
went away together what everyone wants
to know is where are they going and why
our first thought is Nord
beyond the wall as Lake plot says that
these four together with the Hound two
brothers without banners
tormund and few brothers from Night
Watch are going to try to catch a white
in favor to show the nearest and the
rest of the Empire the danger that
threatens them there are some let's call
it proofs
they're going in favor for this theory
and in favor for theory which says that
while John along with his team is trying
to capture white they're all going to be
attacked by the undead army but will be
saved by Daenerys and her dragons let's
start with the fact that Game of Thrones
crew had been quietly constructing a
large snowy set at Wolf Hill quarry in
the hills above Belfast crew has blanked
the area with fake snow and created an
artificial ice surface rather like an
iced over Lake you can also see a large
screen with snowy ground beneath it as
we've said our doubt is that they are
going to be on the wall which feeds the
ice location that the crew was trying to
make as best as they can also in lead
part is mentioned the Jon and his team
will get attacked by night king's army
while trying to catch a white in details
is described that even Jon will lead a
small team they're going to be noticed
and attacked on the icy surface by White
Walkers along with their white army and
the white polar bear in each one Brad
without banners is going to get killed
by ladders will be according to league
plot say by Daenerys and her dragons all
except Jon Jon will be alone
shrunk by White Walkers and whites but
all sudden benjin will appear and say
Jon it's setting wounded Jon barely
alive at his horse while he is going to
stay and fight as long as he can
surrounded by horde of the undead army
there are also rumors about Danny's
dragon most likely bazarian getting
killed by the night king in that battle
and later being resurrected as
is white dragon but this is only a rumor
and there are a lot of unexplained
questions about it like for an example
how could the night king even kill
dragon
however the nearest feel at this point
obviously believe in John statements
about the undead army and the later with
John's help managed to catch a white and
iced over lake snowy ground with fake
snow and the icy surface that the crew
had made seem that it more than fits in
this theory but few weeks ago it was all
confirmed with some hard proofs as we
have three leaked photos in the first
one we can see doing the whites in this
crew mate set which they were preparing
few weeks for the shooting three hundred
stores had been brought on this icy set
which makes this theory almost 100% true
the second photo also goes in favour to
this theory as we can see three main
characters that have never crossed paths
in previous season but are now together
just like theory says and guess where
are they they are the belfast the
location where the crew was preparing an
isis set for a few weeks the third photo
would be a final confirmation for this
theory but it's leaked photos quality is
way to allow in our opinion is john
preparing for filming on this size is
sad now we're only waiting for emilia
clarke or AKA Daenerys to appear on the
side set about Belfast and in that case
we could officially confirm this theory
let's continue with probably the most
exciting scene that is going to happen
in season seven and with the nurses may
enroll in it it's the scene from filming
in southern Spain the Italica said
italic has amphitheatre and Sevilla soil
shipyards will depict the dragon pit
Jeremy Podesta the guy who is directing
the season 7 premiere and the finale was
entirely cut by himself our guess is
that the scenes from Metallica set are
definitely going to be used in season 7
finale there are a lot of reasons that
led us to this conclusion this is even
more exciting once you realize the 13
starring cast members are confirmed to
have a role at dragonpad accompanied by
four guest stars with 17 major care
deters the scenes filming dragonpit will
be the most important scene in season 7
for future events this will be historic
confluence of characters Circe Daenerys
Jon Snow Tyrion Jamie Dallas miss Andy
sander Theon Brienne Varis bran Jorah
urine Qyburn pod and Gregor with all of
these characters being together at the
same place
anything is possible to happen the
reason of all these characters being
together the same place is to witness
the true danger the danger of the undead
army and to unite all of their armies in
favor to stand a chance against White
Walkers and their rights that's the
reason that led the Nerys to invite all
of these characters to dragonpit and to
bring the white over there which Dany
and John together somehow managed to
capture we are not sure how exactly they
managed to pass the wall with wife but
we have a theory for that back in the
first season do you remember when John's
daughter wolf found one dead brother of
the Nights Watch with John which few
other sworn brothers brought to the
Castle black meaning that they passed
the wall do you remember that while they
were passing the wall with him the dead
man was still human but later that night
he became white well in our Theory the
neighbors in John will pass the wall we
found on the dead teammate who died
while John led them beyond the wall
after which they got surrounded and
attacked also the important thing about
this is that the italic has set us
dragonpit along with 17 major characters
is going to have a big role in season 7
and the outcome of that meeting which is
going to be organized by Daenerys he is
going to have a great importance for
events to come in season 8 considering
that most probably this scene is going
to be released in season 7 finale now
let's focus on Saturn mole party down
which the nerves ambush battle scenes
were filming for three weeks as you
already know serves to kill the only
strong Lannisters ally with wildfire
which will resolve it service is gaining
new Alice in season seven new land
search Dalits are going to be as you
have already seen in this video
you're on Greyjoy while the other one is
going to be rendered Tarly who will
probably be awarded with place in small
console but the main result of this
alliance is their march of Highgarden
Jaime leading glennister's army and
randyll Tarly but his Sunday can't are
leading tireless army are going to
attack Danny's Ali's stronghold
Highgarden and the remainder L soldiers
in it which will result the James
victory which is not surprising the him
numbers in both Jaime Lannister and
randyll Tarly have a lot military
experience particularly Randall is one
of the greatest battle commanders in
seven kingdoms after they conquer
Highgarden Jaime along with Randall and
they come with their armies will march
back home with carriages full of goods
loaded from Highgarden while they are
heading home Daenerys will attack them
with her the draggy horde and take an
opportunity to fight him on the open
field this huge battle will start with
the tracking ambush but during the
battle the nurse will also appear riding
dragon how can we know for sure well we
didn't see dragon in lead photos but
from leaked photos we can see a lot of
smoke and bird carriages which we
believe is the result of dragons fire
breeding this battle will end with a lot
of casualties for both sides as we can
see a lot of that man on the ground but
it's going to be the nurses victory
after a few weeks of filming this major
battle for season 7 filming in multiple
data ended about a week ago with all of
the experts precisely for this shooting
seven buses full of experts have been
brought to this location including 60
horses and also there was a green screen
which will with the help of computer
designers generate hundreds of soldiers
into thousands we guaranteed that this
battle is going to be something that we
could compare to the Battle of the
bastards
this Daenerys this victory will be very
important for her with the victory then
he will prove to her enemies that
everyone who won't bend the knee and
everyone who is going to betray her or
her Allie's will be punished and expose
league scene that happened on filming
set nirmaan Partida
the scene that involve our technicians
in a burning stuntman could be an
outcome of the nurses anger entirely for
joining the Lannisters on their March
on Highgarden and for possibly killing
lady Elena who has become Danny's ally
at the end of the sixth season as you
can see there was a huge burst of flame
and the stuntman was set on fire we can
tell for sure which character salmon was
representing but when he was set on fire
someone yelled Khaleesi what sort of
witchcraft is this now they're raising
questions after this scene such as where
the great ball of fire came from and
which character is stunned and
impersonating in our opinion the
stuntman was impersonating randyll Tarly
which is in our opinion going to be
burned alive by Danny's dragon as a
result of Randle betrayal order small
house Tyrell and were pledging their
army to Lannisters the man that he'll
Calise see what sort of witchcraft is
this would be in this eerie rattle
Santaquin Tarly who will after days
become the new lord of the horn hill
below so there is a theory which
involves Dothraki horde but his theory
Daenerys is the track according on
savage Westeros and started raping along
with robbing as we know the nearest is
added towards that it could be that
Daenerys decided to stop the craziness
with setting it attract a Colin fire
this is in our opinion Daenerys
Targaryen fate in season seven supported
by leaked photos and leaked plot hope
you guys enjoyed this video if you did
please make sure to subscribe to our
Channel and see you next one
[Music]
you